we're going to begin though with a big
surprise from the house select committee
investigating the January 6 assault on
the capitol the members voted
unanimously yesterday to subpoena former
president Trump they say they have an
obligation to seek testimony in relevant
documents from him the committee's final
scheduled public hearing presented
details evidence that the former
president set the events of January 6 in
motion we also saw never before seen
video of how Congressional leaders
responded to the attack in real time
Scott McFarland has the story
as thousands of rioters swarmed the
capitol grounds after president Trump
stopped the steel rally we're seeing
house Speaker Nancy Pelosi's reaction
for the first time to being told Trump
wanted to March to the Capitol too we've
been waiting for this the trespassing on
the capitol grounds I want to punch him
out and I'm going to go to jail I'm
going to be happy then later in the day
a new video released by the committee
house Speaker Pelosi has led to a secure
location with other Congressional
leaders they're putting on their tear
gas masks
I believe
I can't in the video recorded by
Pelosi's daughter Senate Majority Leader
Chuck Schumer is heard pleading for help
from then acting Attorney General
Jeffrey Rosen yeah why don't you get the
president to tell them to leave the
capital Mr attorney general and leaders
of both parties are seeing calling the
Department of Defense this cannot be
just we're waiting for so and so we need
them there now whoever you got okay you
also have troops this is study Hoyer
okay so we have a wonderful day Andrews
Air Force Base all right other military
bases thank you we need active duty
National Guard how soon in the future
can you have the place evacuated Pelosi
is also seen and heard on the phone with
then vice president Mike Pence who later
informs her the capital will reopen that
night
in roughly an hour good news during the
hearing committee members argued Trump
agitated the crowd January 6 then
directed them to the Capitol knowing
some were armed and angry the central
cause of January 6 was one man Donald
Trump whom many others followed the
committee used the word premeditated
multiple times arguing Trump and
Associates like Steve Bannon had long
planned to claim victory on Election
night regardless of the outcome and what
Trump's going to do is just clear
Victory but that doesn't mean he's the
winner he's just going to say the winner
the committee also returned its focus to
the U.S Secret Service whom they'd
previously accused of stonewalling their
probe the panel showed intelligence the
agency had seen predicting violence 11
days before the attack they think that
they will have a large enough group to
March into DC armed The Source reported
and will outnumber the police so they
can't be stopped
The Source went on to say their plan is
to literally kill people please please
take this tip seriously and investigate
further and with less than three months
to finish its work the committee has
taken its investigation to the next
level Miss Cheney
aye by voting to subpoena documents and
testimony from the former president he
must be accountable
he is required to answer for his actions
the committee has limited time to move
on this new subpoena in response to all
this on social media the former
president asked why he wasn't asked to
testify sooner than called the panel a
total bust it's only further served to
divide the country Gail
the clock is ticking on this thank you
very much Scott come